now let me make two comments firstly you
will see I have many more axes than
grass and the reason why is because I'm
going to compare in a second each of
these graphs against is derivative so
you'll see me do that then secondly
critical damage is the hanging this is
not a great title for what we're looking
at today it's not like say the phrase
stationary points when you say
stationary point everyone knows what
you're talking about there's no
ambiguity it's a completely agreed upon
term not so much should we talk about
critical values if you say critical
values to one map edition versus another
they'll be like well what what kind of
critical values do you mean as you'll
see essentially i'm using them to
indicate something interesting happens
that doesn't forms are the categories of
the other language it up already told
you about okay as you'll see in the
pictures there are some more there's a
there's a finer definition but like I
said not everyone agrees on it okay so
it's kind of just like an okay name but
don't expect it oh I everyone knows what
these are different texts which would
use it differently as well okay let's
stop I have a look at the first one it's
probably the most familiar out of these
and also the simplest right in some ways
you can actually just grab this without
anything about the derivative but the
derivative is actually what we're
interested in okay so how would you
describe the graph of y equals absolute
value bets it's a number one it's
piecemeal okay and the two kinds of
parts of the peaceful function are it
comes down to the origin and then it
bounces back off in fact that's kind of
what absolute value sign graphs are
often given as a sort of flat definition
the other ones that bounced off the
accents okay no big deal now we usually
would say this is the absolute value X
but since it was pointed out this is a
peaceful function and actually having
the different equations of the branches
of the graph is really useful to us
what's the yard equation of the right
hand side it's just X and over here good
sorry I'm going to use this and I've
love you too if your grass just go down
the page maybe you want to draw these
extra ground
extra axes just to the right of them
okay about my minor underneath I'm going
to grab this time over here X against
its derivative dy/dx ok so i can define
these access to be whenever I want so
I'm going to define it to be derivative
of this guy ok now when you look at this
y equals x we don't need to do any
computation here the derivative of y
equals x just by definition is 11 right
now I can draw that I can pop it over
here ok so here's my derivative do I on
the x equals 1 ok that's all fine that's
the right-hand branch on the left hand
side drew do this guy is this negative
work yeah I'm not finished so maybe
after I'm done you can ask now you will
notice i now have some problems here
right the gravel absolute value of x is
a continuous craft remember when we used
to talk about continuity right so this
contagious I can draw this thing without
lifting up my whiteboard marker and my
pencil right it's defined at the origin
like it passes through there or good ok
I mean if I wanted to make it super
obvious i put a filled circle there but
i don't need to write I don't need to
say anything unusual is happening there
it just continuous ok but when we give
it to hear you have this discontinuity
pretty obviously right it is to find all
the way over here and define all the way
over here but in order to have
continuity in order to have a value
right there in the middle ok do you
remember we talked about this I can talk
about the limit of the absolute value of
x as x approaches 0 from below or from
the left in this context now I can say
well that's equal to the limit of the
absolute value of x when I think about
it from the other direction do you
remember
it's been a while since we introduced
this language of notation so this means
as you're getting closer and closer to
zero if you come from this side or you
come from this side you're getting the
same value you're both going towards
zero or grit but it breaks down here
right you see that the limit as I'm
approaching for the left and then as I'm
approaching from the right have nothing
to do with each other okay so there is a
discontinuity not in the graph but its
derivative does that make sense let's
draw that in shall we it is not defined
for x equals zero so I'm just going to
put it on the line there because they
are very much ok so my dream ian has a
discontinuity here so far so good right
let's now come over here and talk about
the cube root of x ok now you have some
um if you think back to the end of last
year back when you were fresh face t 10
students you would have learned that
this guy here the cube root of x is an
inverse function what's it an inverse
function of yeah it's an inverse of the
cubic function right so we know what
this looks like we have a pretty good
idea of what this looks like ok well my
relationship between this guy and this
guy is that because you swap the X's and
Y's around right you are rotating sorry
you're reflecting this graph to get this
crap how am I reflecting at which way am
I reflecting a weapon I'm going to flip
it across now let me give you the
classic example of an inverse right the
classic example is the exponential
function versus the log function so you
have those there now it's really easy to
see off of that example you just have to
turn your head 45 degrees and then you
put in your x equals y graph and you can
see the symmetry ok I'm getting the same
kind of thing for this graph right this
is the shape i'm going to get
okay so he's my cube root of x right you
notice if you turn your head it does
behave a lot like um y equals x q but
everything is you know reversed around
and if you want imagine my wife was X
through here I'm not gonna produce is
going to cloud my diagram when I put it
in you can do the reflection and you'll
get that what's that call what does the
cube root cube y equals x to you was it
do it the origin it has a horizontal
quite of inflection very good okay now
here everything's being reflected across
everything's off by 90 degrees so
instead of a horizontal point at the
vertical point right so this is the cube
root of x okay now something a little
more interesting happens when I go to
the derivative I'm just going to use
this space over here how am I going to
do something how am I going to rewrite
this in order to make it differentiate
to move yeah okay I'm going to put it in
index form I'm very good at
differentiating things in an index bowl
right so I'm going to say this is number
two y equals x to the power of n yeah so
dy r DX what do we do this thing you
good a third comes out the front and
then the power reduces y 1 mark that two
bit weird but a third take away one is
negative two thirds okay now a third X
to the negative two thirds that's a real
function I don't really know off the top
of my head what it looks like but I can
work out some interesting things about
it fairly easily for instance has a
negative index was that mean usually it
means you're actually not multiplying
again again again that's powers for
usually go but you are dividing right so
this X to the two-thirds really belongs
on the denominator you see that okay now
that you've written it in this form just
like over here without absolute value of
x you see this guy has a problem right
he doesn't need this for all real ex no
discontinuities no discontinuities but
when's it right down
x equals 0 okay now we have this picture
so we kind of have a reason to
understand why it breaks down x equals 0
right what's the gradient at the origin
that's a bit tricky because grading is
rise over run internet rise over run but
it's not running anywhere it's just a
vertical line at that point just like
the cubic is a horizontal line this is
vertically so its rise over the run
happening and we know that division by
zero causes us these problems so what's
this thing going to look like 1 over 3x
to the two-thirds hmm it's always
increasing ah ok so this guy hold on be
careful right as you put in some numbers
we can actually try sometimes good we
have no idea what this looks like write
as X gets bigger bigger and bigger and
bigger bigger what happens to X to the
two-thirds hmm as X gets bigger what
happens to X to the two-thirds it's now
hold on a second oh noes again think
about two numbers right like say a
thousand to the power of two thirds okay
that means you take the cube root that's
the third part and then you square it
this is a hundred okay you're right with
that um what about say a million to the
power of two thirds what's that you do
that you did a cube root right which
gives you only two of the zeros and then
you square it's at 10,000 I think yes
yeah now it's growing it's not going
super fast but it's still growing okay
so if your denominator is growing what's
happening to the whole thing it's
getting small the whole thing is getting
smaller it's approaching the limit of
this as X approaches infinity is 0 okay
so I'm doing something like this right
okay now again stuck the events
derivative right you see how these are
two there see how there's a two i can
rewrite that with the two
further out it's actually a function
that's been squared what do we know
about functions that are square in terms
of those portions it's always positive
so it's always gonna be a body and more
importantly it's even right so if this
is happening here on the right hand side
then over here on the left hand side I'm
doing the same thing I have that even
symmetry okay what's happening in the
middle I can't so X can't equal zero
right it's climbing the mirror like that
okay with a vertical asymptote we know
it's not just that like I'm going to
approach it you can never ever touch it
as opposed to horizontal asymptotes for
chicken cross all the time okay so
really it looks like I'm getting
something like that that's a bit real
okay it's rough but you get the idea
does it gel with the picture that we
have think about it I increasing
function looks like to be increasing at
different rates but does this reflect an
increasing function answer it does
because this is the derivative dy and DX
and it's always positive the sign is
what I'm interested in right if you
wanted to do it like this you would say
green for gradient right all these green
pluses here means this thing is all
about the access that looks good what
about this stuff happening in here does
it make sense over here I'm shallow
close to zero as I approach x equals 0
it's getting steep it's getting really
steep yeah it goes so sleepy Costa very
cool ok so that's why this values so
high and then does the same thing in
reverse okay are you happy with that but
something since by the way um yeah i'll
point out now we were talking about even
symmetry tagrapha theme are there any
other even functions on the board now
if very first of all we drew is an even
function does this have any kind of
symmetry it's all in my support what are
this that's odd and that's even